ok
[Musique]
elle est à toi cette chanson Toi
l'auvernac qui sans façon m'a donné
quatre bouts de bois quand dans ma vie
il faisait
froid toi qui m'as donné du
feuant les croquantes et les croquants
tous les gens bien
intentionné m'avait fermé la pote
nez ce n'était rien qu'un feu de bois
mais il m'avait chauffé le corps et dans
mon âme il brûle encore à la manière
d'un feu de joie toi l'auvernia quand tu
mourras quand le crrooc mort
t'emportera tu te conduises à travers
ciel au Père Éternel
elle est à toi cette chanson Toi
l'utesse qui sen façon m'a donné quatre
bouts de pain quand dans ma vie il
faisait
faim toi qui m'ouvris ta Huch quand les
grqu
et les croquans où les gens bien
intentionnés s'amusaient à me voir
jeûner ce n'était rien qu'un peu de pain
mais il m'avait chauffé le corps et dans
mon âme il brûle encore à la manière
d'un grand
festin toi l'utesse quand tu mourras
quand le crooc mort Temporte
qu'il te conduise à travers ciel au Père
Éternel elle est à toi cette chanson Toi
l'étranger qui s'en façon le malheureux
m'a souri lorsque les gendarmes m'ont
pris toi qui n'as pas
applaudiant les croquantes et les
croquants tous les jeens bien
intentionné riait de mavir
emmener ce n'était rien qu'un peu de
miel mais il m'avait chauffé le corps et
dans mon âme il brûle encore à la
manière d'un grand
soleil toi l'étranger quand tu mourras
quand le crrooc mort
t'emportera qu'il te conduise à travers
ciel au Père
[Musique]
éternel